you have footprints in all of the
sciences so let's talk about the
universe a little bit is the universe at
the lowest level deterministic or
stochastic in your amateur philosophy
view put another way does God play dice
well we know it is stochastic right but
today today we think it is stochastic
yes we think because we have the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle and we
have some many experiments to confirm
that all we have is experiments to
confirm it we don't understand why why
is all your a book about why yeah it's a
puzzle it's a puzzle that you have the
dice if flipping machine oh God
and the in the result of the flipping
propagated with a speed faster than the
speed of light it's right we can't
explain it okay so but it's it's only
governs microscopic phenomena so you
don't think of quantum mechanics is
useful for understanding the nature of
reality no division anyway so in your
thinking the world might as well be
deterministic the world is deterministic
and as far as the null no one firing is
concerned it is deterministic to first
approximation
you